well I like to think of GMO is actually
God move over because I pretty much it's
scientists you know messing with nature
every farmer that buys a genetically
modified seed is doing it for one reason
because they know it's the better seed
there is so much misinformation right
now about this technology that general
public is having really hard time to
figure out what is really true or what
is not Hawaii has been a primary testing
location of genetically modified
organisms or GMOs for decades many of
the largest biotech companies conduct
research on new strains for commercial
crops and produce genetically engineered
seeds to sell to farmers across the
country
Hawaii is very important to agricultural
biotechnology Elysium blue fe t is a
spokesperson and lobbyist for the seed
companies in hawaii what they're really
doing here is nursery work they're
looking at the types of crops transgenic
or biotech or traditional to help
farmers the most by doing that here in
Hawaii
instead of like Iowa they're able to get
three to four growing seasons after
their commercial release in the 1990s
the relatively quick adoption of the
transgenic crops by farmers in the US
and abroad sparked a loud and colorful
reaction of fear and condemnation by
activists and the media therein 80% of
the food we eat but some say genetically
modified organisms pose serious health
risks is this stuff safe to eat should
people be worried about a sort of let's
call them Frankenstein foods gardening
is our future not GMO given hawaii
central role in the development of GMOs
the debate here will undoubtedly affect
food sources for the rest of the country
and even the world these chemical
companies think that they're gonna win
oh hell no why is ground zero against
GMOs for the whole
world last year after pressure from
protesters to islands in Hawaii have
placed restrictions on testing and bans
on new research we believe is homme and
there's certainly potential harm and you
know once these things are released into
nature you can't call them back there's
no recall mark Ferguson is the president
of the organic Lobby group hoffa
Hawaii's organic farming Association he
is one of the most vocal opponents of
GMOs in the state and the CEO of the
vegetarian grocery store down to earth
eat organically for the sake of yourself
for the sake of your family and for the
sake of the environment
genetic engineering or genetic
modification is actually one of many
tools that is available to farmers to
help them deal with the big problems
like pests and diseases and weeds
dr. Anya was Erick is a scientist and a
professor at the University of Hawaii we
have been doing dramatic genetic
modification on crops for for hundreds
of years so this is not really the most
accurate way of describing the
technology that we're talking about
first way would be called transgenic
technology they're doing something which
cannot be done in nature and that is
crossbreed species so they're actually
taking genetic material from completely
different species and inserting it using
sort of quite crude technology like they
call it a GMO gun of putting different
genetic material into genes of plants
the natural products industry the
organic industry initially was trying to
move well let's get these things banned
in the 1990s Hawaiian papaya faced near
devastation after the invasive ringspot
virus threatened to destroy fields
across the state that drove dr. Dennis
Gonzalez to use transgenic technology to
essentially cut and paste
genes into the papaya to protect the
plant from the virus many medicines from
insulin to eads drugs were now
genetically engineered perhaps he
thought the same techniques could help
plants as well the GMO rainbow papaya is
widely credited with saving the papaya
industry in hawaii in honoring dr.
gonzalez for his contributions to the
agricultural industry here in hawaii and
throughout the world political will or
political clout it was not there to ban
them
okay well let's label them so at least
people can see oh I'm eating GMOs give
people a choice it's a food even a
biotech food or even an organic food has
any nutritional difference toxin or
allergen you have to label it that's
already the mandate one of the big
misconception is that genetically
engineered crops are the ones that are
really modify and DNA is change and
everything else is pure as nature
created
majority of crops that we use in
agriculture today have been modified by
modifying the DNA over the hundreds of
years even for classical breeding or
mutation breeding or tissue culture or
genetic engineering you almost have no
product on the market no agricultural
crop that has not been modified by
scientists or farmers over the years
this group of people that have a
religious and philosophical opposition
to the science and really it's anything
that is they perceive to be unnatural
our position is is no we've been doing
this for thousands of years now we're
just doing a little bit more specific it
doesn't make sense to spray all kinds of
poison on stuff it doesn't make sense to
put poisons into the crops themselves it
doesn't make sense to mess with nature
as people learn about GMOs they go well
I don't want to eat GMOs what I find it
very interesting is that these crops
genetically engineer crops are the only
crops that we actually test for safety
these crops are as safe as the crop that
have not been genetically engineered
there is extensive Studies on human to
make sure that they do not affect the
human health to make sure that they
don't cause allergies that they not
being toxic and so on and all the years
we have no reports scientifically based
reports that would show that these crops
are not safe overwhelming the science
supports the safety and the health and
nutrition of biotech crops the testing
is done by the companies themselves
naturally they have a self-interest to
only do studies that show the crops in a
good light but research has produced
over 2,000 peer-reviewed scientific
reports that document the general safety
and nutritional value of GMO foods and
feeds well over 1/4 of the publications
are created and funded by organizations
that are entirely independent from large
commercial seed and chemical companies
if someone would tell me that they think
that my opinion is what it is because
big companies sponsoring my research
which they don't or this building is
owned by Monsanto which is not and I
will find it really insulting by tell
me that my opinion is based on money I
went to university and studied for many
years to do what I do if you want to
become rich you don't only become a
scientist Anya is not alone
every single major health and science
body in the world which includes Europe
we're politically motivated restrictions
exist has concluded that GMOs are no
more risky than conventional plant
breeding the American Association for
the Advancement of science states the
science is quite clear crop improvement
by the modern molecular techniques of
biotechnology is safe genetic
engineering is just a tool so right now
we're using this tool to you know
increase the yield or help with the
insects but these tools can be used to
clean up environment we can create
Venton ethically engineer plants that
might be able to clean up pollution and
as we using this tool in agriculture or
in the environment we got to use it
carefully but we cannot just throw it
out because we don't understand it can
be religious reasons can be moral
reasons can be what and it can just be
hey I live in a democracy I've got the
right to know if we're changing the way
that we operate we have to come out with
new rules so what are we going to say
we're going to say we're going to label
genetic engineer crops because public
wants it if we're ready to do that
that's fine but when we have to ask our
saw the question what happens in
tomorrow public wants something else on
the label only time will tell if GMO
labeling is productive one thing is
clear scientific truth is not and should
not be subject to a majority of votes
for reason TV I'm Sherif Mattar